It's time for don't buy it, DIY It.
(crowd cheering)
Our next guests are a DIY duo who have more
than two million followers on YouTube, alone.
They have even more on other platforms
and they're all about easy projects
that won't break the bank.
And they're about to show us one now
in honor of our DIY week,
please welcome Kelsey MacDermaid and Becky Wright
also known as The Sorry Girls.
(crowd cheering)
Hi, thanks for having us.
Thank you so much for-
So excited.
joining us today.
Now, quick question,
you're named The Sorry Girls, you're from Canada.
And is it because people say, sorry in Canada a certain way.
Yeah, you got it.
That's pretty much it as (chuckles)
as well as the fact that we started our YouTube channel.
We didn't know what it was gonna be about
but we knew we were Canadian and that wouldn't change.
(crowd laughing)
Well, I love it.
Okay, so you guys have another series
that I'm obsessed with because it's called,
"That cost how much?"
Exactly.
And I hear that pitch in my head
and I'm so appreciative
that you guys have the show called that.
I think is it coming out of most of our mouths
when we do look at the price tag,
So you're gonna DIY something
that's normally really expensive in stores.
Becky, what do we DIY-ing today?
Today, I'm gonna show you how you can DIY
your own stone.
Ceramic inspired lamps.
The best thing about this is,
that you can do it with a lamp that you already have
that you don't love anymore.
or maybe one from the thrift store.
We're also gonna be DIY-ing the lampshade too
which is a Scandinavian inspired trend.
That's coming back and lamps like this can cost over $200.
So we're gonna do it for a lot less today.
All right.
Walk me through this.
Okay. So first off, for the base,
we have some regular old house paint here
and we're going to add in a couple tablespoons
of our baking powder.
This is going to give us texture, lots of textures
and then start mixing it a little slowly.
Start making like a moose texture.
that's what we're looking for here.
I love that.
If it was a different color, we'd kind of wanna eat it
but we're not going to,
so don't eat it.
(chuckles)
Because if it was pink, it would look like cotton candy.
I was thinking like more chocolate,
chocolate is my (indistinct) for sure.
Oh yeah, I might've eaten a chocolate Cub kink
over my sink last night.
(crowd laughing)
One of those nights.
Oh, wow.
Are you getting the texture?
Oh, wow you guys! this is amazing.
I've never seen anything like it, it's like moose.
Once we have some of our textured paint
we're just going to go ahead and put it on our base here.
We're gonna wanna go to the same direction
because think if we're trying
to replicate some natural stone pottery.
We want to kinda go the same direction.
So I'm just going horizontally across the base.
And don't smooth it out too much
because we want that texture really come through.
And when it's all done
and dried, it's gonna look something like this.
The texture showing through
and looks a lot more expensive now, I think.
All right, Becky is gonna show us how to do the lampshade
to finish it all off.
All right, so what we've already done
for the shade is actually taken apart,
the one that came with the lamp.
We've deconstructed it, taken the fabric off.
So we have the ring left
and we're gonna be making a new shade entirely for this.
Okay, so to make this we're doing it out of card stock.
This is eight and a half by 11
and we're gonna start by just folding accordion style,
about three quarters of an inch.
Are you with me Drew?
I am very with you.
Okay, we are repeating this process a bunch of times
until we have a long sheet that looks like this.
Our aim is to get a piece of accordion style paper.
That's about twice the circumference
of the shade that we're going for.
And how do you add here the pieces together?
May I ask?
You can just use plain clear tape
because we don't wanna see it.
So any simple craft tape will do the job.
Just take all your pieces together
until you have a long accordion of these lifestyles.
So there's one more step we need to do
before we can attach it to the shade.
And this is really simple.
It requires using a whole punch
to punch a series of holes along the top
and the bottom of the shade.
And you'll also wanna do a little slit with some scissors
so that we can access the hole punches, okay?
And this is what's gonna let us clip our shade
on to the rings.
This part is so simple.
It's amazing.
So all you need to do is take your ring.
And then with the hole is that we've made
just go ahead and clip them right
on to the ring, all the way around in a circle.
Okay, I got it.
Are you now clipping on your shade to your ring?
Aren't you gonna believe it?
I'm so amazing.
(crowd cheering)
(sighs)
Look at that!
And then we just put it with the base
that Kelsey showed you earlier.
And Oh my gosh, this lamp got a face lift.
(crowd clapping)
These are super chic, super expensive.
Honestly, around what price point
do you think you could genuinely do this for?
So, assuming you already have this lamp,
all you need to buy is the paper and the paint
which I think could cost you less than $10 to do.
Okay, I love this, you guys.
I really wanna do this with you again.
Will you please come back and we can DIY ourselves silly?
Of course, we'd love to.
Thank you Kelsey and Becky,
and be sure to check out The Sorry Girls
on YouTube for even more fun DIYs.
(upbeat music)